[Musique]
[Musique
] c'est la première fois que je
reviens au Marineland d'Antibes depuis
fin 2002 quand je dirigeais le puits
tueur c'est très pénible pour moi d'être
ici c'est très inconfortable mais je
sais aussi que c'est  très important que je sois
ici parce qu'il est important que
tout le monde sache la vérité sur les
épaulards en captivité je sais ce qu'il y a
juste derrière ce mur et mon esprit
j'ai tellement de souvenirs des souvenirs incroyables
avec les baleines parce que je les
aime mais aussi des souvenirs horribles  à cause
de ce qui leur arrive en captivité, l'
essentiel est que ces animaux
qui, dans la nature, nageraient une centaine de
kilomètres ou plus par jour avec leurs
familles naturelles et resteraient avec leurs familles
à vie sont maintenant réduits à des
familles artificielles dans un traitement chimique
boîte en béton la quantité de chlore
qui est utilisée dans cette eau juste pour essayer de le
rendre clair afin que les gens puissent voir les
baleines est enly thil et je peux vous dire
par moi-même d'avoir des yeux bu  rns et
les baleines brûlées lorsque les systèmes
fonctionnaient mal et que du chlore était
constamment injecté dans les piscines
pendant la nuit, les baleines étaient si
gravement brûlées qu'elles ne pouvaient même pas ouvrir les yeux
pendant trois jours et des feuilles de
peau se décollaient d'elles,
je pourrais continuer  et sur et sur les exemples
de ce qui leur arrive en captivité, les
bases de la formation des animaux sont la
privation de nourriture Je ne peux pas faire faire à un orque de 8 000 livres
quelque chose qu'il ne veut
pas faire si je leur demande de le faire et ils
disent  non et nager, je ne peux pas physiquement les
forcer à le faire, mais ce que nous faisons, c'est que
nous ramassons nos seaux et que nous nous éloignons pour
qu'ils n'obtiennent pas leur nourriture car ils ont de
plus en plus faim, ils deviennent plus
susceptibles de faire quoi  ils ne voulaient pas faire
en premier lieu, alors ils disent que
les puits peuvent choisir ce n'est pas un
choix qui a faim mais quand nous sortons
et que nous faisons un spectacle, nous les formateurs sommes
là pour vendre un produit nous sommes là pour
montrer au public une façade on est là pour
dire regarde comment gr  mangez c'est regardez comme
tout le monde est heureux regardez comme je suis
heureux regardez comme les baleines sont heureuses le spectacle
et les déclarations de relations publiques qui ont été publiées
sont des mensonges absolus qui ne sont pas la vérité
ce n'est pas le monde réel pour ces
baleines qui sont en captivité elles  vivre une
vie horrible en captivité et
chaque orque captive est morte de maladie
et de maladie pas une seule orque dans aucun
parc du monde n'est jamais morte
de vieillesse ce fait seul devrait
parler de lui-même
[Musique]
vulnera spectaculaire mauvoisin président
extramédullaire ELO  de BOSU avec la la
Nashua al fondo so extra no imminent
payment no Alvo motrin a yellow vest
Absalom Andy de el Roboto Mia Lynn
occupation total Eskimos Vardhan Libous
under here deja des animaux und Munoz
repetitive Jason Sin Cara Grande soy
sauce Pskov wala say yo Sebastian  et
Antonio un feeder ici sur Desert Rose
rock on hand fair to Solomon move more
to Solomon mouvement le long du mouvement
s'appelle des terreaux TPS sur cendre
maletto a dit vaca nouveau nom scientifique
rangée séparée monte de Sol non permanent
comme la Fidele Imelda nuke en un autre
destory CP vs Ace Cafe de nuke yo gel
basé sur Jessica's la propiedad on so a
total novice so Sunday's an emoji dorian
fucose de la nuit  de la nuit une détresse
[Musique]
quelques placages Podesta podia
dentistes d'urgence aujourd'hui pour en ik + c'est un
jour de catastrophe pas de nouvelles même dépôt usine suivez-moi
retour à la cruauté contramar à La Mesa
- : la logistique de la ville seule à Nuuk
Nopalito
la ligne de fond quoi  vous voyez sur
cette photo avec une note que vous voyez la
mort vous regardez un animal qui
est en train de mourir sous vos yeux
et vous avez des gens tous les jours qui font rouler
leurs enfants et une poussette à l'intérieur de ce
parc pour voir ça  si vous voulez amener
votre famille voir des épaulards, vous
ne le regardez pas bien tueur ce n'est
pas un tueur bien cette baleine est dans la
fleur de l'âge à 20 ans et
il n'y a même rien dans ses
caractéristiques physiques qui représentent un  animal en bonne santé
entre trois parcs différents et
travaillant avec 20 orques captives différentes au
cours de ma carrière je n'ai jamais vu d'
orque captive avec des dents ce lit ses
dents sont inexistantes vous ne pouvez même pas
dire qu'elles sont mauvaises elles ne sont pas là
est-ce ce que vous voulez enseigner à votre
famille est-ce celui-là que vous voulez apprendre à
vos enfants que c'est ce qu'est un tueur
bien ce n'est pas un tueur bien
c'est un tueur bien qui meurt
sous vos yeux à cause de la captivité
et  ils y contribuent parce
qu'ils ont payé un billet
et ils sont passés par le tourniquet
c'est un mensonge c'est une abomination
toi